[Música]
nós gostaríamos de começar uma pergunta
muito simples quem é que sabe quem fez
as suas roupas
a roupa que você está vestindo hoje
neste momento quem sabe levantar a mão
algumas pessoas só olha só
vocês têm o costume de olhar na etiqueta
interna para saber de onde elas vieram
levanta a mão
otto quinho mais que bom mas ainda nem
metade da sua fala a gente não tem
realmente muito esse costume
boa tarde o selo iso arthuso olá eu sou
o fernando e simon e eu vou começar
contando uma história pra vocês
no dia 24 de abril de 2013
um acidente abalou o mundo o hana plaza
era uma fábrica que abrigava diversas
confecções de roupa ela desabou em daca
capital de bangladesh
mais de 1.100 pessoas morreram e mais de
2500 pessoas ficaram gravemente feridas
muitas dessas pessoas para incapacitados
de trabalhar novamente
este é considerado o pior acidente da
indústria da moda de todos os tempos
muitas pessoas morreram costurando
milhares e milhares de peças para
atender a nossa vontade insaciável de
consumo marcas que provavelmente todo
mundo aqui conhece estavam produzindo
lado na plaza acidentes como este são
freqüentes na cadeia da moda
principalmente nos países asiáticos mas
o trabalho análogo ao escravo também é
uma realidade no brasil é muito mais
comum do que nós podemos imaginar
diversas marcas já foram flagradas em
2016 40 milhões de pessoas foram vítimas
da escravidão moderna do mundo muitas
costurando roupa
vale ressaltar que a força feminina é
extremamente significativa nos
victor ela representa mais de 80% da mão
de obra na indústria da moda
muitas dessas mulheres são mães de
famílias
um outro problema sério é a questão do
trabalho infantil é estimado só no
brasil
senti 14 mil crianças e adolescentes
trabalho na indústria da moda
então quando a gente pensa em moda a
gente pensa em beleza a gente pensa em
glamour
a gente pensa nas passarelas mas qual é
o bastidor dessa indústria
os bastidores da indústria da moda podem
esconder grandes impactos ambientais
também a indústria considerada uma das
maiores poluidoras do mundo na china na
índia por exemplo as pessoas têm o
costume de dizer que podem prevê a cor
da próxima temporada
só de olhar para as águas dos rios o
cultivo do algodão é responsável sozinho
pelo uso de 24% de inseticidas do mundo
todo prejudicando claro a biodiversidade
local ea saúde dos agricultores
hoje nós consumimos 400% a mais do que
há 20 anos a gente adquiriu esse hábito
nas duas últimas décadas de consumir
mais e maior velocidade mas com menor
qualidade
só no bairro do bom retiro um pólo de
confecção em são paulo são descartadas
12 toneladas de retalho por dia
o excesso de descarte de lixo um dos
grandes problemas que o mundo tem
enfrentado hoje
então esse modelo de produção e consumo
muito rápidos que tão imperando mercado
hoje em dia já se provaram que não já
provaram que não são saudáveis nem pro
ambiente e nem pras pessoas e pedem por
mudanças urgentes
diante deste cenário nós percebemos que
definitivamente a moda precisa de uma
revolução e nós acreditamos que esta
revolução começa dentro de cada um de
nós é bom
em 2007 eu tive uma experiência
espiritual que mudou minha vida para
sempre
sabe que a maneira que eu vivia não
estava conectada com a realidade do
planeta
eu me dei conta de questões como
mudanças climáticas limitação de
recursos naturais aumento populacional
crise hídricas e teológicas econômicas e
não me sentia mais conectada com o que
eu estava fazendo e na época eu estava
na faculdade de moda né ea moda se
tornou algo distante de mim
bom eu fui para a inglaterra em busca de
uma nova vida uma vida mais conectada
com a natureza procurar uma carreira
mais humana e nesta minha caminhada eu
encontrei marcas e profissionais que
trabalham com moda ética ecológica
sustentável então foi quando este
universo se abriu na minha vida então eu
percebi o poder da conscientização eu
percebi que a moda pode ser uma chave
para a consciência
então a partir dessa conscientização
sobre os impactos ambientais os impactos
sociais escondidos atrás das nossas
roupas
o indivíduo pode perceber de uma forma
sistêmica de uma forma holística que nós
todos estamos conectados tudo está
conectado
então as nossas mudanças de hábitos por
exemplo que a gente come o que a gente
veste o que a gente descarta o que a
gente usa pode ter um impacto positivo
na nossa vida na vida das outras pessoas
das próximas gerações no planeta bom
durante alguns anos a morena inglaterra
eu estudei e trabalhei na área onde
diversos profissionais e até aqui em
2013 quando hanna plaza da boca
o prédio é alguns profissionais que já
trabalham com moda ética ecológica
sustentável decidiram se unir e dizer
basta a esse tipo de situação pra
garantir que acidentes como hanna plaza
nunca mais voltem a acontecer
e foi assim que foi criado o fashion
revolution
o fashion leva luxa é um movimento
global
está presente em mais de 90 países e tem
como objetivos conscientizar sobre os
impactos ambientais e sociais a
indústria da moda celebrar as pessoas
por trás das roupas exige maior
transparência e fomentar uma indústria
mais sustentável
bom em 2013 e não em 2014 eu voltei para
o brasil trouxe um movimento para o
brasil e foi assim que o luisão nos
encontramos nos unimos nossa jornada e
começamos uma ativação nacional
realizamos diversos eventos ações
palestras com outros profissionais
também com outras iniciativas como um
uma agência de inovação e
sustentabilidade e também como brasil
apple faz ruir a primeira semana de moda
sustentável do país
dom nós acreditamos que a moda teve a
considerar medidas iguais a criatividade
o lucro as pessoas eo meio ambiente que
nós não podemos continuar produzindo e
consumindo da mesma forma mas a moda tem
o poder de transformar essa mesma moda
que nos aprisiona num ciclo constante de
consumo e diz essa pode ser a criadora
de um novo desejo do desejo de um futuro
mais sustentável mais ético mais
inclusivo
eu trabalhei como estilista por mais de
dez anos
até me dá conta de que a moda que eu
fazia não fazia mais sentido para mim eu
percebi que lá valorizavam muito pouco
as pessoas envolvidas nos processos a
procedência dos materiais o tempo de se
fazer as coisas à qualidade a
criatividade é essa aqui na foto é a
fabiana ela era uma estilista que
trabalhava comigo nessa viagem que a
gente fez para a china para desenvolver
produto
vejam que quase não dá pra enxergar lá
atrás da mesa eu estava bem ali na
frente dela por conta dessa quantidade
de materiais e foi aí que eu comecei a
me perguntar se a moda poderia ser maior
é mais sentido para quem produz e para
quem consome e se ela poderia contar
boas histórias e foi tentando resgatar o
que mais valorizavam na moda a qualidade
e criatividade e saber fazer o tempo de
se fazer as coisas que eu entendi que
ela podia ser ainda muito mais
ela podia ainda ser ética e sustentável
e foi aí que eu mudei eu mudei a maneira
como eu trabalhava eu mudei a maneira
como eu comia como eu consumia eu mudei
até como eu me relacionava com as
pessoas e com o ambiente volta do
trabalho
foi uma mudança pessoal profissional
quase espiritual mas é extremamente
gratificante porque a moda tem esse
poder
ela tem o poder de criar mudanças
positivas
ela tem o poder de trazer uma imagem
compartilhada do que realmente é
verdadeiro e belo
o que é realmente belo o que é realmente
verdadeiro o que é realmente precioso né
para mim por exemplo para uma roupa ser
considerada preciosa ela precisa
carregar uma bela história ela precisa
ser feita por pessoas satisfeitas
pessoas que são valorizadas pelos seus
trabalhos pelo que elas fazem luxo pra
mim é a dignidade luxo é respeito
lucho a igualdade engajamento né como
por exemplo este vestido de algodão
orgânico colorido naturalmente a paraíba
ele foi feito por diversos agricultores
rendeiras artesãos todos liderados pela
francisca vieira natural cotton color
uma grande referência na moda
sustentável brasileira e uma prova que
se faz moda com ética e justiça assim
ou então como o tênis da morte que é
feito com o athex tem solado feito com
látex natural da floresta amazônica
um trabalho que ajuda a preservar um
saber
local ajuda dar força ao trabalho dos
seringueiros que quase já foi esquecido
e também preservar a floresta
então dar força ao trabalho local ao
trabalho manual tudo isso podem ser
garantidos através de uma ferramenta que
a transparência
então você já pega pararam pra pensar se
quando vocês compram um produto aquele
preço pago é o preço real
será que os impactos ambientais estão
naquele produto traga qualidade de vida
das pessoas que costuraram plantaram que
serão está embutido no preço de cada
produto é como que a gente pode saber
disso
pensando nisso algumas marcas decidiram
abrir o custo de cada um de suas partes
cada uma de suas peças
então assim elas podem comprovar o
trabalho digno é e o comércio justo
este é o caso da marta catarina mina que
produz bolsas com mulheres artesãs no
ceará
ela é referência no prazo no brasil
através de um projeto chamado uma
conversa sincera no qual em seu site
cada peça traz um relato transparente
sobre a sua precificação
nós estamos vivendo um momento de
transição onde é colocar a economia
global está abalada sendo questionada
elementos como transparência inovação
criatividade nunca foram tão importantes
será que ainda faz sentido continuar
produzindo e consumindo da maneira com
que a gente vem fazendo pelas últimas
décadas
claramente repensar os nossos hábitos
setor no essencial e não por uma questão
de ideologia mas por uma questão de
sobrevivência
a qualidade das nossas vidas depende
dessa consciência mas claro que repensar
e questionar uma economia global
é um desafio enorme então trazendo por
uma escala menor e talvez não tão menos
desafiadora é
pode começar pensando sobre o que a
gente está fazendo hoje quais são os
impactos das minhas ações no mundo
nós como consumidores temos um poder
enorme nas nossas mãos
através do nosso dinheiro nós
incentivamos essa ou aquela marca a
continuarem atuando da maneira que atua
o ato de compra se torna um ato político
porque a gente pode sim através da
compra incentivar e criar mudanças
positivas na vida das pessoas gerando
renda inclusão social através de
empregos dignos como por exemplo o plano
social
eles são um negócio social eles atuam em
prol da paz social
então além de trabalharem com algodão
orgânico nas suas coleções
eles também capacitam empregam ex
presidiários
esse é o seu paulo ele foi o primeiro
contratado pelo plano social 65 anos ele
aprendeu a cortar costurar a modelar
sozinho durante os 26 anos em que esteve
preso
ele acredita que ele já faleceu mas ele
acreditava que a costura podia trazer
dignidade à vida das pessoas em situação
de vulnerabilidade social
então transparência informação nos
ajudam a criar a escolha de com escolha
de compras mais inteligentes
nós podemos pensar na nossa próxima
compra
se ele é um produto local se eu estou
comprando tem procedência éticas e é
feito de matéria prima de baixo impacto
se essa peça é atemporal cela tem
qualidade para durar
será que a gente precisa realmente de
mais um produto será que a gente não
pode usar o que a gente tem
será que a gente não pode cuidar melhor
do que a gente tem
será que a gente não pode trocar os
nossos amigos freqüentava as áreas de
troca comprado de segunda mão customizar
nossas roupas refazer as nossas roupas
alugar roupas
se nós queremos
mundo diferente nós precisamos pensar de
uma forma diferente e nós precisamos
agir de uma forma diferente
o mais importante é que nós repensamos
as nossas roupas
os nossos hábitos e pensar o que eu
posso fazer o que você pode fazer né
qual será o futuro do amanhã
eu acredito que a moda ela tem o poder
de transformar nós lutamos por uma moda
mais justa mais digna e eu gosto de ser
positiva sobre o futuro das roupas e do
planeta
por isso eu acredito que no futuro todas
as roupas a cadeia da moda inteira será
sustentável não como diferencial não
como uma exceção mas como uma regra
porque afinal quando a gente está
falando em sustentabilidade
a gente está falando em preservação
ambiental estamos falando em preservação
cultural em direitos humanos
isso tudo já é um dever e uma missão de
todos nós em nossas mãos nas mãos de
cada um de nós
essa construção do amanhã hoje nós
estamos desenhando o futuro que a gente
quer viver e deixar para as próximas
gerações
por isso têm consciência dos nossos atos
é tão importante essa é a verdadeira
revolução a consciência por isso se
perguntem sempre quem fez minhas roupas
ligada
[Aplausos]